вітаємо шановні глядачі Це прямий ефір з
Києва з Хрещатика прямий ефір з дня
незалежності України
видалитися Deutsche Welle українською
Українську службу німецької хвилі мене
звати Анна пшомиська як кореспондентка
два українською Отож сьогодні День
незалежності 32 річниця проголошення
незалежності безперечно це свято для
кожного українця але це ще й той день
коли півтора роки тому рівно півтора
роки тому почалося повномасштабне
вторгнення Росії в Україну тому водночас
це і сумна дата але судячи з атмосфери
сьогодні тут у серці України ми бачимо
що люди святкують люди збираються тут і
дивляться на такий собі своєрідний парад
російської техніки ми Вам сьогодні все
детально покажемо розкажемо
поспілкуємося з людьми покажемо що
сьогодні тут є цікавого
нагадаємо вас писати коментарі залишати
свої відгуки питання пропозиції у
коментарях під цим відео цю трансляцію
Ви можете бачити і на Ютубі і на
Фейсбуці будь ласка підписуйтеся на
сторінки до джерела української у
соціальних мережах де вам буде зручно і
залишайте свої відгуки Ми з радістю їх
озвучуємо в ефірі редактори будуть мені
передавати ваші питання і пропозиції
Отож давайте трошки більше подивимося що
тут сьогодні відбувається це такий собі
своєрідний парад знищеної російської
техніки яку знищили українські військові
не лише від початку повномасштабного
вторгнення адже варто пам'ятати що війна
в Україні почалася не 24 лютого 2022
року а набагато раніше ще в 14-му році
тому ось наприклад Ось ця
самохідна артилерійська установка
міста російська брала участь у боях на
Донбасі ще з 2014 року Тут також ТРК
представлені це все символізує
символізує те що плани росіян плани
Володимира Путіна захопити Україну
швидко 22-му році провалилися вони
мріяли пройти парадом очищатику але
бачимо щось з цього вийшло торік такий
самий парад в лапках відбувався в Києві
але було трошки менше експонатів
зі зрозумілих причин цього року колекція
поповнилася
Ось там трошки тут ще бойові машини
піхоти бо бойові машини десанту тут
представлено 28 різних експонатів
російської техніки і ця виставка
тягнеться дуже далеко насправді від
Майдану і до перехрестя з вулицею
Богдана Хмельницького і тут зрозуміло що
перекритий рух для автомобільного
транспорту І це все буде тут
виставлятися до 28 серпня тому якщо буде
у вас нагода то будь ласка
завітайте це досить цікаво як бачимо
багато людей тут зібралися сьогодні
попри те що напередодні і ще за кілька
днів до дня незалежності у КМДА і
зокрема мер Києва Віталій Кличко
закликали не проводити жодних масових
заходів і до таких обмежень вдалися не
лише у столиці А і В усіх українських
містах
насамперед тривогу викликало те що ста
Чернігові минулої суботи російський
обстріл центру Чернігова Коли російська
ракета влучила в драматичний театр де
відбувалася виставка Дронів згинули
семеро людей більш як 150 Звернулися до
медиків саме тому зараз ми розуміємо що
невідомо чого можна очікувати Тим паче в
таку символічну дату як 24 лютого от як
24 серпня Перепрошую
сьогодні у Києві вже звучала повітряна
тривога як і по всій Україні через
черговий зліт міг 31к в Росії
мусимо вас попередити що якщо буде
повітря на тривога то ми будемо змушені
призупинити цю трансляцію Тому що тут на
Хрещатику зокрема
патрулює поліція тут є військові тут
досить багато муніципальної поліції яка
просить людей проходити в укриття якщо
звучить повітряна тривога зі зрозуміли
причин знову ж таки тому що настрої
тривожні і в ГУР попереджали що сьогодні
можливі провокації можливі обстріли тому
варто бути обережними і в разі чого йти
укриття також ось хочемо звернути вашу
увагу на ось ці експонати це броньовані
машини тигр такі собі аналогов нет ті
машини якими дуже пишалися в російському
оборонпромі вони Одним із перших
висадилися у Гостомелі і ми бачимо що з
ними сталося
в цивільному варіанті така машина коштує
від 100 до 120 тисяч доларів у
військовому варіанті зрозуміло ще більше
Тому
це це досить таки значно досягнення для
України що знищено вже кілька десятків
таких тигрів і Ми продовжуємо і
українські військові продовжують їх
знищувати
також хочемо відзначити що цього року є
і нова експозиція тут ось там прошу
показати оператора там де найбільший
ажіотаж людей там де найбільше людей
сьогодні
тут представлені
тут представлені збиті російські ракети
збиті російські дрони є тубуси від
снарядів ми підходимо з заду так би
мовити тому що через натовп людей
пробратися неможливо Ось там так Якщо
видно в кадрі Сподіваюся видно
костюм російського військового з
балалайкою дуже цікавий експонат
А ось тут просто біля нас
уламки шахедів
електроніка усе начиння
усе начиння з цих іранських Дронів якими
Росія атакує українські міста
досить багато людей сьогодні на
Хрещатику від самого ранку
тому що лише сьогодні вранці цю виставку
відкрили ще напередодні тут було все
перекрите І лише звозили техніку тут
можемо бачити
виставку таку собі Не дуже приємних
речей це міни
різних типів і протипіхотні і
протитанкові які можуть ховатися які
росіяни можуть ховати де завгодно тобто
він небезпека це дуже важливо зараз і
військові на цьому наголошують
а далі шнурок протягом
Да шнуровки ви зараз шнурок зацепили
тримав зарвався
Я хочу нагадати що це прямий ефір до
вишивали українською тому будь ласка
приєднуйтеся до нас у коментарях пишіть
свої відгуки побажання і пропозиції ми
зараз спробуємо запитати Чи можемо ми в
когось дізнатися більше про експонати
які тут представлені
Скажіть будь ласка прокоментувати нам
можна
це
Я розумію це військові вони не дуже
охоче коментують всі ці питання але я
сподіваюся що згодом ми все ж можемо
трошечки більше в них розпитати про про
те що тут можна побачити
поки що пропоную трошки більше
подивитися на виставку і поспілкуватися
з людьми запитати про їхнє враження про
те хто як святкує якщо святкує взагалі
День Незалежності
Доброго дня Скажіть можна будь ласка
кілька питань
Що для вас день незалежності означає і
Як святкуєте якщо святкуєте
День незалежності особисто для мене
означає перше боротьбу нашу тобто свій
день це нагадування про те що нічого в
цьому світі Просто так не проходить
[музика]
нашу країну А чи святкуємо день бо я
особисто
як би сказати
Ну не то щоб я гуляв на цей день але цей
день
і рік від Минулого дня незалежності яка
от подія чи новина така була з вашої
точки зору найбільш важлива і позитивна
для України
я от можу сказати що наприклад для мене
це мабуть було звільнення Херсона тому
що я не з Херсона сама але ось ці відео
з міста звільненого перші перші якісь
кадри Це було дуже вражаюче Що для вас
Ну я повністю
[музика]
територій Це звісно завжди такі радісний
момент в нашому житті навіть якщо ми там
не перебуваємо в даний час
але зараз за цей рік Мені напевно важко
сказати які тільки Щасливі дні у нас
бувають тому що кожен день він важкий до
нас але важкий до наших військових
Тому треба про це пам'ятати завжди і
треба Завжди знати що ми стоїмо тут Тому
що вони там
і з того часу було доволі багато
приємних новин як приємних так і
неприємних Я вважаю що не можна Їх
ділити як якусь визначну або невизначну
новину вони всі важливі і вони всі
ведуть до нашої Перемоги
спасибі Вам Велике дякую вам гарного
вечора
ваша мені глядачі теж просимо вашу думку
висловити в коментарях під цим відео я
Нагадую що цю трансляцію можна бачити і
на Ютубі і у Фейсбуці тому будь ласка
висловлюйте свою думку про те що для вас
день незалежності і яка подія чи новина
для вас символізує цю незалежність
українську що такого сталося за минулий
рік від минулого 24 серпня 2022 року Що
вам запам'яталося найбільше що у вас
вразило Що для вас символізує
незалежність Ходімо далі
дуже багато людей у вишиванках сьогодні
дуже багато людей з українськими
прапорами
на цих зразках техніки написано що їх
варто не чіпати і не залазити на них але
все одно люди дивляться що там всередині
фотографуються
Доброго дня можна кілька питань вам
згадати
не всі хочуть спілкуватися розуміємо це
так буває
дуже багато іноземців до речі сьогодні
тут є і журналістів тобто іноземної
преси і просто чути іноземців тут на
Хрещатику тобто люди люди цікавляться що
тут відбувається Доброго дня можна вам
кілька питань задати будь ласка
Скажіть будь ласка ви місцева з Києва чи
приїхали і я приїхала з міста героя
Миколаїв дуже приємно що вас привелося
сюди навчання
студентка
Скажіть будь ласка чи святкуєте День
незалежності І що це свято якщо це для
вас свято означає для вас це велике
свято День Незалежності і ми повинні
Кожен рік одягатися у синьо-жовті
кольори і виходити на жаль вже другий
рік нас позбавили нашого святкування ми
не співаємо наших пісень вони танцюємо
немає такої святкування але все ж таки
це велике свято тому що ми незалежний
народ і ми прагнемо бути незалежним
Скажіть будь ласка яка подія або Яка
новина за останній рік від Минулого дня
незалежності на вашу думку така найбільш
значма найбільш позитивна для України ну
або для вас особисто
а позитивно напевно коли от ми бачимо
танки і ми бачимо просто труд наших
хлопців що вони там не зря бо
сьогоднішнє свято завдяки нашим хлопцям
з яким нашим котикам якби не вони просто
не було б у нас не було в Україні тому
що Слава Україні Героям слава спасибі
Вам Велике
дуже українською дідовою на Ютубі на
Фейсбуці це зараз прямий ефір тому ви
вже побували в прямому ефірі Спасибі вам
ось тут ми можемо бачити уламки ракети
якщо не помиляюся це Точка У
теж викликає неабиякий ажіотаж
[музика]
Доброго дня можна вас спитати що за
напис тут залишають
за своїх хлопців знайомих за свій за
своє місто ви з Фастова Так
у вас рідні чи знайомі на фронті так у
мене Діана фронті мене вся сім'я
Скажіть будь ласка що для вас день
незалежності чи свято це чи святкуєте я
не скажу що святкую але це точно день
коли потрібно знати за що ми стоїмо за
кого хто воює там і пам'ятати Наші герої
Спасибі вам
Так це дійсно дуже таке болюче питання і
важливе питання зараз тому що
зараз триває український Контрнаступ він
триває великою ціною але є і позитивні
новини і одна із
позитивних таких хороших звісток була
про те що українські військові
просуваються на Запорізькому напрямку в
біля селища роботи це відкриває дорогу
на Токмак тобто за останні буквально
кілька тижнів за останній тиждень почали
з'являтися ці новини і це піднімає дув
але безперечно Важливо пам'ятати про те
що зараз відбувається і що сьогодні не
лише свято
[музика]
Хочу додати трошки статистики адже за
останніми соціологічними опитуваннями
уже більше як
65% українців вважають де Незалежності
головним святом а в 2013 році наприклад
ця цифра становила лише 12%. тобто за
останні роки за останні 9 років
кардинально змінилися свідомість
українців і ми Буквально за кілька
хвилин за годину до ефіру тут теж
спілкувалися з людьми і багато хто
відповідав Що почали святкувати День
незалежності з 2014 року Тобто ми бачимо
які зміни відбуваються у суспільстві
сьогодні від самого ранку тут на
Хрещатику дуже людно тобто під час
повітряної тривоги яка сьогодні була
після обіду по всій Україні поліція
пройти викриття і чимало людей пішли в
метро але зараз
знову всі тут зібралися і
ажіотаж величезний людей ще більше людей
стало Ще більше ніж вранці
Я хочу нагадати що сьогодні таких
особливо якихось святкових заходів у
Києві не було але до столиці прибули
лідери іноземних держав сьогодні тут
були і президент Литви і президент
Португалії і хочу нагадати що Португалія
також оголосила що долучиться до
тренувань українських пілотів на
винищувачах f-16 це для України дуже
важливо тому що
ще цього тижня Данія і Нідерланди
пообіцяли що і починаю тренування
українських пілотів і нададуть Україні
винищувачі тепер і Португалія
приєдналася офіційно до цієї коаліції
також є ще є Ще думки я ще заяву у ЗМІ
про те що можливо і Норвегія долучиться
А зараз я бачу нашого колегу
кореспондента deuts
velamesias працює для іноземної
аудиторії Deutsche Welle працює для
німецькомовної і англомовної програм і
насправді дуже цікава людина навіть
говорить українською що для нас дуже
дуже приємно дуже цікаво
я найперше хочу запитати як тобі
атмосфера тут на Хрещатику І взагалі у
Києві сьогодні ну відчувається що у для
людей це цікава багато хто тут дивиться
на цю техніку і Насправді всі вже чують
про цю техніку кожен день в новинах там
і тут можна глянути в Києві і до цього в
останньому року можна було глянути ну це
гарне гарне так і повість щоб вийти і
людям потрібен на цей це це це це
відчувати трохи а
насправді живу у у всіх по-різному але
якась там
все-таки
які стресу всех дає з цих це
відчувається ще відчувається насправді
що якщо ми
віді- їдемо звідти звідси трохи більш
туди що дуже мало людей мало машин
багато хто просто у їх і
користував цією ціннішого дійсно
відчувати десь за містом Тут є багато
людей і і і видно що багато хто тут
надягали якісь там вишиванки і щось таке
красиве
прапори багато
бачимо але насправді Я думаю що більш
Людей просто
відпочивати
сьогодні є така на
[музика]
года Він багато кому порадили наприклад
не виходити сьогодні на роботу тому що є
все-таки якісь ризик провокації є ризик
обстрілів про це попереджали ну тобто
все-таки Трошки так насторожено люди
ставляться Я наприклад сьогодні вранці
не побачила великих заторів там де їм де
по Києву Тобто Ну дійсно як ти кажеш
трошки пустельно на інших вулицях я щось
ще хотіла натяну тебе запитати а Ти
зустрічаєш в Україні з перших днів
повномасштабного вторгнення то тут
висвітлюєш що тут відбувається Чи можеш
ти виділити якусь подію чи новину яка
тебе найбільше вразила або історію яка
тебе найбільше вразила Ми щойно таке
запитували у людей там люди говорили там
і про наших українських військових і про
там ми згадували про деокупацію
території що для тебе найбільше
запам'яталося що тебе найбільше вразило
в мене це дуже важко сказати я тут сюди
приїхав дійсно за ну 1 січня
2002 року
багато часу немає було щоб тут
ознайомитись з країни там чи
щось там там відразу буде треба було
багато працювати і
початок війни Я теж тут застав ми були
якраз в Донбасі тоді приїхали потім сюди
Я не можу сказати що було там одне е-е
одна подія чи і якась одна історія яка
там А мені більш всього впечатлила була
багато дуже ну
ну дуже різних вражень і була дуже
багато
подій багато відчуттів
приїхали ми як і всі не знали що буде Я
пам'ятаю Тут е-е
Хрещатик
зараз він перекритий люди тут ходять Но
тоді в березні теж можна було ходити тут
похрещатику Тому що там може бути там
кожний 5 минут якась машина приїхала
можна було
відійти пропустити і далі там і і не
була нікого майже нікого в місті Там ми
бачили тільки багато хто виїхав А але ще
й багато що не не хотів вийти до на
вулицю ну всі люди ну практически всі
коли були на на вулицях вони чи вони з
магазину експертами чи вони
зіпсом чи
там
видно видно було Що тільки ті люди яким
потрібно вийти і вийшли А зараз Бачиш
як це це змінилося і це Ну во всіх
містах були небагато там сумних історій
люди які втратили якогось там із
близьких людях які
втратили свої дії Люди там
дуже-дуже-дуже багато було А але
це було ну це було дуже інтенсивний
період і якщо думати півтора роки це не
дуже багато часу а Але в той період це
були дуже це дуже багато
вражень бо дуже багато чого відбувалося
І ці
дні коли тут не було нікого і ми не
знали що буде далі що
зайдуть ліс сюди росіяни чи ні вони так
далеко і це це так далеко вже
відтепер що це дуже дуже
складно представити
що взагалі Це було тобто тут під Києвом
стояли російські танки буквально вже на
околицях вони були і зараз мені здається
що багато людей тож те саме відчувають І
от в Україні вже говорять про те що
часто люди кажуть Ми втомилися людини і
зрозуміло що військові найбільше
втомилися від війни і цивільні кажуть що
це ну тобто це вже півтора року це
насправді не мало Ось і дуже тривожні
такі публікації у західних ЗМІ
з'являються з приводу того що і на
заході відчувається якась втома від
новин з України і залежно від цього може
і підтримка якби зменшуватись підтримка
озброєння фінансова України що ти скажеш
цього приводу як кореспондент який
працює для іноземної аудиторії чи цікава
досі Україна чи відчуваєш ти якусь втому
від новин з України ну є
два різних від
втомитися одне це втомитися дійсно від
того що відбувається те що тут у
багатьох людей і те що там теж це ж не
неприємні новини і кожен день а
втомитися в тому що вже Ми не хочемо з
цими ніяких там стосунків мати це я не
відчуваю у нас на каналі я е-е Ну дійсно
це ну звісно це це не так
як це було
півтора роки тому коли це
ну ну
24 години в день Да в добу говорить
тільки про те є якісь інші якісь там
новини які теж мають своє місто в наших
випусках але
це все що цікавить людей і ми все ще
бачимо що це ми що ми викладаємо
в мережу про Україну це користується
кліками там клікнуть на це це
користується
цікавий І ми теж
не відчуваємо що
підтримка вона кудись ну витрим
підтримка звісно вона не така активна
там мітинги І це так все таке що було
але вона продовжується і ми не бачимо
щоби там якась
частина велика
в Німеччині чи в інших країнах
вже хочу щоб ну зав'язати з цим і і не
мати ніяких стосунків тут цього чи а не
підтримувати далі ми не бачимо що там
якісь
закінчується грошей які там
уряд може виділяти для України чи ну
підтримка вона продовжує
все ще цікавить людей але уже на на
такому з більш
[музика]
на такому рівні Який такий перевищений
як це було ну якщо це
порівнювати з іншими там
воїнам які були там в інших частинах
світу
ця війна вона цікавить люди набагато
більш вона
хвилює людей набагато більш це
відчувається досвід
дякую тобі матієз Дякую за твою роботу
то це і за те що долучився до нашого
ефіру
Дякую тобі дякую будемо відпускатиметься
бо він ще має свої прямі ефіри нагадаю
що це був миті збілінгер кореспондент
deutschevel який працює тут в Україні з
перших днів повномасштабного вторгнення
працює для англомовної і німецькомовної
програми Deutsche Welle Ми поговорили
трошки про враження від того що сьогодні
відбувалося відбувається у Києві також
зачепили тему втоми від війни в Україні
і особливо на заході хочу також додати
що насправді там попри те що часто зараз
якщо спілкуєшся з людьми то багато хто
каже що там втомились від обстрілів
Втомилися Втомилися військові втомилися
від того що постійно на передку на
фронті без ротації але все ж таки якщо
ми поглянемо на статистику то більшість
людей тобто більшість українців понад
80% говорять про те що не готові йти на
поступки Росії поради Миру тобто мир
будь-якої ціною це зараз не та історія
навіть якщо Росія продовжуватиме
обстріли українських міст продовжуватиме
обстріли цивільної інфраструкту
інфраструктури все одно більшість людей
підтримують те щоб боротьба
продовжувалася тому зараз якщо ми
говоримо про якусь втому то це лише тому
що ми розраховуємо ми розраховували на
якусь там коротку дистанцію вважають
люди а потрібно йти довшу тобто зараз
зараз усе ще продовжується так були
прогнози про те що
українські військові зайдуть в Крим
наприкінці весни 2023 року ось наприклад
Кирило буданов про це говорив У жовтні
2022 року цей прогноз як бачимо не
справдився але сьогодні сьогодні ось
вночі сьогодні рано-вранці точніше
військові українські і українські десант
висадився на ми
завдали ураження російської техніці
ліквідували Кілька десятків російських
військових і крило Богдана заявив що так
дійсно мій прогноз не справдився але все
ж таки звільнення Криму військовим
шляхом буде тобто рано чи пізно це
станеться це відбудеться
побачимо знову ж таки як як будуть
розвиватися події далі ми зараз знову
біля
цієї цікавої експозиції з російськими
дронами і ракетами Я би хотіла все ж
таки дізнатися чи може нам хтось
розповісти детальніше про те що тут
відбувається і що ми сьогодні можемо тут
побачити
Скажіть будь ласка міг би нам
коментувати
представник центру трофейних озброєнь
який результат
України
Доброго дня Доброго дня пане Олександра
правильно
так як лише оператора пане Олександре
представтеся будь ласка і розкажіть
трошки про центр трофейних озброєнь
центру вивчення трофейних перспективних
озброєнь який ви представляєте Так я
полковник Олександр заруба Я начальник
інформаційного аналітичної відділу
центру досліджень трофейного та
перспективного озброєння тут на цій
експозиції представлені
озброєння оснащення російського бійця
це те чим займається наш центр Ми
досліджуємо
практично всі зразки які попадаються на
особливо новітні зразки мета дії нашого
центру це виявити новітні технології які
зустрічаються в російському озброєнні
по-друге
виробити заходи і визначити засоби якими
можна уражати техніку противника ми
по-третє фіксувати
випадки порушень норм міжнародного
гуманітарного права скажімо нанесення
ударів по цивільних об'єктах які На жаль
зустрічаються досить часто в цій не
спровоковані агресії Російської
Федерації скажіть чи можемо пройти ось
туди трошки на початок експозиції
подивитися на експонати
тут дуже багато всього цікавого є
насправді торік якщо не помиляюся такою
експозиції не було але за останній рік
зрозуміло що
експозиція і об'єкти для вивчення у
центру трофейних озброєнь значно
розширилися Розкажіть будь ласка що ми
тут бачимо Я так розумію це уламки
російських ракет знищених силами ппу так
Саме так це уламки російських ракет
самих різноманітних як балістичних ракет
так як крилатих ракет які ми противник
наносить удар у нашій території
як повітряного базування так і ті які
здійснюють куски
наземних комплексів Ну і в тому числі
морського базування маршруту
кинжал давайте запитаємо наших фахівців
більших в цьому в цьому питанні
вважалися такими що сили ППО ніяке
взагалі не можуть їх збивати але як
виявилося дуже таке можуть і вже більше
десятка кинджалів збили Українські сили
ППО Розкажіть будь ласка Якщо можете чи
є тут ці гіперзвукові ракети які ми так
пишається Росія
Доброго дня тут є лише фрагмент а саме
фрагмент керма ракети 9с77 60 кінжал
звідки цей фрагмент знаєте
я не можу сказати звідки цей фрагмент
але точно це не
збитий кинджал Тобто Це був прильот і
оце саме такі частини Вони залишаються
цілими неушкодженими все інше воно
розлітається і розсипається майже на
молекули за рахунок її великої швидкості
великої сили удару
Скажіть будь ласка чи можна використати
ось якусь інформацію про Ось такі ракети
тобто що корисного є для збройних сил
України що можна використати з того з
тих з того брухту ось який вдається
знайти там на місці прольотів чи коли
збивають ракету Так звичайно навіть
брухт це є досить цінне в плані
інформації тому що ми
залишається компоненти електронні
компоненти і крилатих ракет і
балістичних ракет які ми потім
досліджуємо і в них можете знайти
інформацію про те що в цих зразках
досить багато компонентів іноземного
походження
і ми досліджуємо саме які мікрочіпи які
інтегральні схеми використовуються
подаємо таку інформацію і потім санкції
які накладаються на російську федерацію
і на конкретній фірмі які постачають
електронні компоненти в Російської
Федерації Це в тому числі частина нашої
роботи
Так це інформація вже опублікована Росія
почала власне виробництво шахрів
»
бачити нанесення ударів невідомої
третьої силою по території Росії і
ви не також мож- можете в інтернеті в
багатьох інших джерелах побачити
Ось такі заклики які ви спочатку
на
експозиціях і виробники представляють
трони українського походження і досить
великою дальністю а це означає що
Україна має можливість розробки
безпілотних літальних апаратів великої
дальності які у разі необхідності будуть
застосовані по тих цілях які будуть
визначені
Олександр скажіть на вашу думку який тут
такий найцікавіший експонат зразок
Можливо щось унікальне можете написати
тут серед цього відділу
Всі ці речі цікаві це от центроплани з
крилатих ракет це двигуни
по чернігову коли був нанесений удар як
правило після підриву
крилатих ракет ну в основному крилатих
ракет то залишається навіть такі великі
частини двигунів
і це ті технології які були ще більшості
випадків ті технології які були ще
розроблені за часів Радянського Союзу і
це теж цікаво
є зустрічається і технології які нові
для нас
технології які знижують радіолокаційну
помітність
крилатих ракет і балістичних ракет
ми це все відсліджуємо і даємо нашу
рекомендації для того щоб їх також могли
збивати
»
електронні плати Саме ці електронні
компоненти якраз вони виробництва
західних іноземних фірм найбільш
критичні з них який також застосовується
в
ракетних технологіях крилатих ракетах і
балістичних ракетах - це
високопродуктивні чіпи Ну скажімо тут
представлені
фірма ксіллінс чи Спартан це якби
центральний ядро центральної
обчислювальні елементи
високопродуктивний який дозволяє і
ракеті І от засобом артилерії досить
швидко проводити обчислення і
попадати по тій цілі яка запланована
артилерійськими засобами або попадати
крилатою ракетою балістичної ракетики
якраз
тому що саме тому
необхідні ці санкції і це
це робота на майбутнє мабуть не тільки
для України а для всіх країн які повинні
об'єднатися і припинити ці ланцюжки
постачання тому що
ефекти глобалізованого світу коли
електронні компоненти можна купити
на відкритому ринку на відкритому ринку
їх можна використати в плюс можна в
мінус можна на благо можна для для того
щоб нести смерть людям і це ті питання
які в третьому тисячолітті буде стояти
не лише перед Україною а наш оце- оця
наша війна - це привід для того щоб над
цим задуматись
Скажіть будь ласка що це за така система
цікава схожа на комп'ютер з монітором
Саме так це все Системи які із машин
управління
вогнем артилерії
вони саме ведуть обчислення
цілей і нанесення по них ударів це
виконання Це той самий комп'ютер але
виконання його військове в
антиударному корпусі от ви бачите такий
от
шарик трек болт так
проти досить масивний такий от ну
виконання Досить таке ще Ну з точки зору
дизайну досить примітивне але
щодо безвідмовного Я б не говорив не
говорив так категорично це техніка вона
будь-яка техніка може відмовити а тим
більше от така от
з таким залізним шаром
досить важкою
ящик так вони відстають в технологіях
від західних країн і ми це бачимо на цих
зразках озброєних
манекен колоритний дуже так манекен
колоритний на ньому представлена
уніформа російського солдата
ми досліджуємо самі різні речі і
високотехнологічні речі і досить
примітивні відомі з давніх часів Ну що
може бути нового в формі проте форма -
це теж технологія І от ми досліджували
тканину на такій формі вона не є
маслостійкою вона досить гарно горить і
це означає що російські солдати в
техніці він перепадання
боєприпасів які спричинені пожежу йому
буде спричинена Ну він буде горіти
просто-напросто А ще якщо ви бачите на
екрані полонених росіян
то вони завжди такі засмальцьовані у
вигляді
це саме саме тому що це це властивість
тканини з якої виготовлена ця форма вже
через деякий час кілька днів перебування
В окопах чи знаходження в техніці і
змастилом із паливно-мастильним
матеріалами вона набирається всієї цієї
грязі і вони виглядають такими чорними і
засмальцьованим
проте навіть в цих технологіях росіян є
деякі речі які вони роблять уже досить
давно скажімо от
вставки і виготовлені скелерових тканин
Вони мають власне виробництво келерових
тканин і виготовляють захисні костюми
для екіпажів бойових машин Ну і для
штурмових підрозділів і ця ця технологія
яка розробляється Вона дозволяє
захистити солдата від дрібних осколків
ну в тому числі навіть
пістолетного пострілу
це те над чим ми теж працюємо і де теж є
певні успіхи
А ви можете сказати звідки ці всі
експонати Які ми тут бачимо з яких
конкретного регіонів напрямків всі ці
експонати вони фактично звідусіль
більшість їх зібрана під час
наступальних операцій коли противник
кидав і техніку свою і
озброєння і екіпіровку оснащення Тобто
це під час відступу противника з-під
Києва це під час
наступу під Харковом і під час
Херсонської наступальної операції на
Запорізькому напрямку
і якісь книжки зошити документи так як
трофейними вважається ну трофейним
озброєнням вважається не лише власний
саме озброєння а в тому числі і
формуляри на бойову техніку в тому числі
документація яка
ведеться разом з цією технікою і
документи офіцерів бойові документи
довідник офіцера російського
такі документи ми їх теж вивчаємо тому
що це реально це їхня тактика це
для того щоб зрозуміти яку техніку вона
використовують скільки скільки вона
напрацювала коли вона вироблена де вона
обслуговувалася все це приносить
інформацію
сухі пайки сухі пайки дуже багато Їх
було під час
відступ відступу з-під Києва власне і ви
могли бачити в інтернеті багато
відеосюжетів коли самі різні люди
розпаковували байки і влаштовували таку
от
дегустацію
розпаковка да
він цілком придатний для вживання ми не
ризикували правда його пробувати
але
мабуть всі наші громадяни всі глядачі
дочевели розуміли от що до війни
причетні не лише ті хто приходять і
стріляють не лише ті хто виробляють цю
зброю а навіть виробники от такого
паштету печіночного
які постачають
елементи для сухого пайка російського
солдата
всі Ці робітники цих заводів всі їхні
сім'ї вони всі фактично причетні до
війни і страждань в Україні
Скажіть будь ласка серед тих озброєнь
серед тієї техніки яку вдалося захопити
Що на вашу думку таке найцінніше було
за ці півтора року вже повномасштабної
війни
таких таких речей було досить багато
особливо тема яка
у всіх на слуху і яка ретельно
досліджується спеціалістами центру це
безумовно безпілотні літальні апарати
тому що це ті речі які завдають удари
ударні безпілотні літальні апарати які
задають удари по нашій території по
цивільному населенню Ну і спричиняють
втрати для серед наших збройних сил І от
ми можемо пройти до наступного степу
небезпечними апаратами
Це звісно досить високотехнологічні речі
Ну скажімо
безпілотна літальний апарат елеон 3 СВ
використовувався до
широкомасштабного бойових дій в тому
числі використовувався з цивільною метою
тобто для того щоб контролювати
стан електромереж
для того щоб контролювати державний
кордон для того щоб контролювати
газони і нафтогени
спочатку
широкомасштабної агресії Ну і раніше теж
почав широко використовуватись в
розвідувальною метою і
ми і несе він розвідувальну інформацію
відповідно для збройних сил Російської
Федерації потім за цією інформацією
наносяться удари по наших військах
він невеликий профіль його
досить непомітний Скажімо так на певній
висоті у нього електричний двигун який
не так шумить як от двигуни внутрішнього
звуку помітити але шкоду він приносить
досить значну
апарат клуб фірма зала
виробник не лише цього
Куба який ударний Дрон наскільки так
удар бойова частина близько 3 кг
от саме От такі дрони можуть наносити
удар по нашій бойовій техніці і ну
спричиняти втрати серед особового складу
крім того Та ж фірма залу виробляє в
тому числі ланцети які завдають досить
дошкульних ударів по нашій бойовій
техніці Ну і низкою цілу низку інших
безпілотних літальних апаратів
[музика]
орлан-10 мабуть найбільш широкопоширений
безпілотний літальний апарат
розвідувальний який
дешевий виробництві ви бачите от як
кріпляться частини
крила на хвіст його можна розібрати
зібрати на полі бою і правити розібране
завдання і він коригує відповідно удари
теж артилерії нанесення ударів ствольну
артилерію ракетними системами Він же за
його якби інформацією можуть наносити
удари і самі ланцети по бовій техніці
досить такий
неприємний ну дешевий відносно але але
але дешевий
з 14-го року власне з початком
вторгнення Росії в Україну воно
розпочалося не В 22-му році в 14-му він
дошкуляє нашим збройним силам
цивільному населенню
наші наші інфраструктурі так
інфраструктурі найбільш дошкуляє от
шляхет 136 з якого тут представлений
двигун
двигун саме от якщо ви чули як Як він
жужить коли летить оце саме будинку
ухвало оце саме він це саме він
нещодавно буквально три тижні тому я теж
чув як він жужав поблизу поблизу будинку
А це його а це його бойова частина
бойова частина близько 30 кг вибухової
речовини і коли от така річ підривається
в ну дуже багато епізодів досить
трагічних епізодів коли ці шахи де
наносили удари по цивільних цілях ну і
там з того шахеда ви можете бачити ще
один елемент який називається за
кінцівка крила і на ньому Ви можете
бачити інший напис герань два от росіяни
для певного маскування для мабуть для
власного іміджу нанесли таку назву
герань два
[музика]
це виробництво так і рану проте
виробництво уже локалізоване в тому
числі і в Росії і вони виробляють ці
шахиди або герані шляхи до 136
виробляють в тому числі в Росії
так електроніка з нього це теж ті
компоненти які досліджуються ретельно
досліджуються
для того щоб визначити заходи протидії
найбільш типовими для
таких дальнобійних Дронів є орієнтація
за допомогою супутників причому кількох
систем супутників GPS і навіть
китайської
системи і плюс інерційна система яка
дозволяє йому навіть
при дії засобів радіоелектронної
боротьби продовжити шлях до цілі і потім
вийшовши із зони дії
засобів реп
продовжити коригувати свій курс і
володіти до своєї цілі п Олександре таке
питання наостанок багато кажуть про те
що зараз ця війна це війна Дронів вони
дуже активно застосовуються Як би ви
оцінили співвідношення сил зараз між
Україною і Росією і чого нам бракує В
цьому плані найбільше Так ви цілком
провів
це і була стаття така в нью-йорк Таймс
якщо не помиляюся Саме так названа де
наша війна була названа війною Дронів і
це цілком вірно Якщо я вам нагадаю
трошки зміст цієї статті то там
говорилося що саме українські військові
якби досягли певних успіхів в
використанні навіть не таких Дронів а
менших навіть цивільних Дронів мавіків
Дронів якими регулярно наносяться удари
по російській техніці озброєння
тобто якщо Росія набагато раніше
зрозуміло важливість безпілотних
літальних апаратів оскільки вони ввели
фактично безперервні війни
останні Грузія А до цього була Чечня
де
війна в умовах гір в умовах
де не могли б застосовуватись літаки
змусила їх використовувати безпілотні
літальні апарати і вже тоді вони ввели в
структуру артилерійських підрозділів
підрозділи от безпілотних літальних
апаратів
і вони це зрозуміли Раніше у них
набагато більше було Дронів при вступі
от війну повномасштабну війну Але ми теж
не тільки
зрозуміли це не тільки доганяємо але
ми маємо певні успіхи навіть на цьому
напрямку Я сподіваюся що ми
переможемо не тільки Загалом у війні Але
в тому числі в війні Дронів багато в
чому так це війна Дронів і якщо на
сьогодні за допомогою
безпілотних літальних апаратів
вже навіть виявляють міні поля
вже є
варіанти евакуації поранених за
допомогою безпілотних літальних апаратів
вже використовується БПЛА досить потужні
які можуть переносити досить великий
вантажі
Тобто це той напрямок який буде дуже
широко розвиватися звісно у нас ще в
Україні не доставляють посилки як
Сполучених Штатах Америки за допомогою
безпілотних хребтальних апаратів але
технології під час війни вони
розвиваються досить швидко і я думаю що
після війни в Україні
буде дуже багато спеціалістів які
це цей напрямок піднімуть і
ми побачимо їх застосування цих Дронів
цивільних цілях пане Олександре Спасибі
вам велике за екскурсію за детальні
пояснення нагадую Це був полковник
Олександр заруба представник центру
дослідження трофейних та перспективних
озброєнь спасибі Вам Велике пане
Олександре Слава Україні Героям слава Ми
на цьому будемо завершувати нашу
трансляцію Нагадую що Це був прямий ефір
Deutsche Welle українською з нагоди Дня
Незалежності з центра Києва з Хрещатика
будь ласка підписуйтеся на цієї сторінки
develle українською соцмережах Twitter X
Facebook YouTube Telegram Стежте за нами
для вас там завжди є свіжі новини цікаві
репортажі ексклюзивні інтерв'ю будь
ласка долучайтеся спасибі що були з нами
і